welcome to this video this is the
highlights video the brief summary of
round six of the candidates tournament
let's get right into the action the
first game to look at is Anand against
kayaking are not before this one leading
the tournament with plus 22 wins no loss
kayaking is on a couple of drawers and
one loss so not a great situation but
history he's playing black and well we
got yet another Berlin defense an
opening for which I am certainly respect
for being a very reliable weapon but
it's sometimes a bit boring this games I
mean this is simply the case ok on erdus
going for the end game he's not playing
d3 again so we actually get the Berlin
Wall end game and yeah this despite
being an early end game and all the
possibilities that both sides have I
mean really this is one of the good
things about this dis opening the
structure from a practical point of view
they are actually quite a number of
options that both sides have and you can
really mix up plans so despite that
there have been some theoretical debates
that really go find two into the game
more than move 20 and in fact we follow
a line that has been played in the last
couple of years yeah h5 to block on the
King side and now naija 5y tries to get
one of blacks bishops to ya get rid of
the bishop hell yeah black is covering
this nicely with the rook on 86 so he
uses the rook that very often has
problems with entering the play simply
because black a sport castling rights
yeah a couple of months later we see
some trades and in fact the rook will
recapture only six black took on c3
spoiling the pawn structure and now loop
d8 yeah the thing is this position was
already reached in gay
spica aachen both with white and black
and allen's new idea was the straight
yang and then play rook to h1 and
kayaking I really invested some time
here to figure out what the best
response is played 95 and Bishop g3
violent yeah here of course black could
take on c3 but this is really a risky
decision because rook h7 combined with
f4 needs to a substantial initiative for
white maybe it is not so terrible for
black but it is it is risky he decided
to play g5 and I like this move for a
much more because it's a just stopping
this F form porn roller and it's a very
human mood for i believe c4 and 93 yeah
and i could have tried without see four
but the problem was that also black was
intending to play night air force oh
here he pushed this here neither for
Jack wasn't great white keeps this pawn
and we'll get to f4 ki can went here and
now aren't activated the King ruck g six
and A three keeping the spawn here in
fact I believe that we she should have
played check King at Luke edge a check
and try to set problems this way um here
I actually believe that black car needs
to be quite precise to to keep the game
here on equal terms something like that
for example can be an idea and now James
e6 you have a funny idea and I think
white retains some pressure look em h8 I
mean it's not a winner of a piece note
that this some might might have been a
chance to to put more pressure on
tracking already played a three and
after that black got this night 36 the
ideal post it covers all the important
squares and check a couple of moves
later we see that
Black has set up really a fortress-like
position exactly here the grain at the
game the game was a greet drawn yeah I
think this is fair result white really
has no way to make any any sort of
progress is just just a fortress that is
possible to to take down so certainly a
result that bloke both players can be
can be okay with Arnaud keeps his lead
he didn't risk anything was never in
danger and put some slight pressure and
I can maybe this is okay Jade move was a
bit more testing but in general I think
our nerd is quite quite content with
this game okay next game to to look at
is Mammadyarov against swidler
Mammadyarov is on minus one he lost two
games early then 1 1111 game yeah and
villas on +1 again after he beat stop
all of yesterday so one interesting
starting point for this game it's
realized coming up with a big surprise
he placed the Dutch defense probably for
the first time in his life in a serious
game and yeah quite quite a surprise
when Tommy dro from place the first
couple of moves quickly and not very
surprisingly within the Dutch like went
for the the Leningrad which is by far
the most optional I'm within Dutch
territory yeah here black also has see
696 but okay queenie ate the most
popular most him a major event for
really weird sideline be form the idea
before is not revolutionary in the
landing-grid but in this particular
position it is very uncommon because
quite often before works better with the
bishop on b2 and the night on d 2
instead of c3 and we see that really
quickly black is getting your fine
with FIV for some yeah suna gets an
active game because this if all porn is
always blocking the bishop so yeah the
other way round makes more sense the
bishop is not waste biting on this bond
and well both sides activate their
pieces f3 designed to actually do
something with the Bishop Bishop e6 and
now we have some complications in the
center now why does winning the spawn
jack but black has a counter-attack with
b5 yeah around here we get to the
critical phase of the game um black has
an active position yeah he has got an
active rook and good bishops so when
there is really no reason for him to be
afraid of anything I think like has a
perfectly acceptable position here white
could have played Bishop d5 which leads
to a very long complicated line after
this capture couch oops not Queen III of
course queen e to white can play 96 and
this line in fact will lead to a
draw-off the King h8 Queen to d5 am
quite a quite a complicated line at the
end this will end in a draw after for
instance this oops sorry okay three is
wrong of course neato oh sorry you need
to take him and after this for example
this leads to a check I got I confusing
myself him check check this is what
Mammadyarov had calculated and later
demonstrated in the press conference he
wanted to fight this is in fact a bit
risky not taking the scan of draw played
King III a queen III and here and I
believe black is actually quite okay
after move like Queen d7 he might even
be more comfortable he played the pawn
capture though
Bishop c5 Quincy eight bit of a weird
move Quincy 8 is big suspicious to me
and I don't really know what what it is
doing I be honest with you I couldn't
figure out the big idea behind it I mean
one idea comes apparent after white
plays h4 here and the idea is really a
strange once we let us now playing the
move age 6 which he later described as
that his brain somehow shut down at this
point I don't know if this were the
exact words but yes if you look at the
position and you ask yourself why isn't
this born hanging on g6 yep it is white
can just take it and i really don't know
if it as simple as that that he
overlooked that the porn is saying he
took some minutes on the move it's not
like he had accidentally touched the
edge form after that wider just takes on
g6 and wins the game it's as simple as
that this this position is beyond saving
already um I really thick if you don't
know how we could come up with this age
6 move he played Bishop to d5 and a
couple of moves later we see that after
rookie six now Mammadyarov has a good
chance to transfer into a good end game
was Bishop f7 and they were good is just
a tumult and expression why does winning
actually check here in this position
this is a quite quite nice very nice
finishing move now that Madonna was able
to play in this position which is quite
funny because of those hanging rooks he
played the very strong with Luke g5 and
this is in fact very aesthetic move it
takes the bishop and the rook is still
being attacked so there's not much else
than taking it after this capture only
three why does winning the endgame he's
got the a pawn and the age porn
and two passes in opposite color to
bishops and game that are so far apart
from each other and a and H bond is as
far as as possible it's just a win and
in fact swidler after Luke g5 already
resigned the game so tough loss for him
he was just back in the race with a plus
score after his willing and supportive
and now he's losing again with somewhat
strange game I mean age six is really
completely inexplicable while okay
Mammadyarov no he started with minus two
and yet some some really bad games the
game way he gave away the Queen early
against Aronian and it it didn't really
look good but now he's on fifty percent
so it's not like he's out of it with
fifty percent and similar situations
let's say kramnik last year in London he
also wants on fifty percent after six
rounds if i'm not mistaken and then
decided to win game of the game somebody
off has fought himself are back into
this tournament that's not not bad at
all alright so next game to check this
is the quick summary the part of against
Kramnik yeah to paula fun playing d4 and
we got a queen's gambit declined in this
in this yeah very tense nervous
encounter while the history with the
world championship match in 2006 they
both really are yeah not on speaking
terms they don't shake each other's
hands and so on so it's a really a match
of two to get to it to enemies to say
yeah topalov is playing Bishop a form
the most ambitious choice in the Queens
gambit nowadays and not be deserving as
chroman expect line the part of place c5
which i consider to be the most testing
move really and after nine h5 also a
means that chronic has played before
more than
the power of went for Bishop b5 which is
a rare move it's only a plate only been
played a couple of times before I'm c6
and now Bishop d3 are very normal one
idea of this Bishop to e5 move is that
in the other position where you have the
bishop on air form like here black will
very often take it and now here you let
your bishop or you give up your Bishop
under different conditions this can be
either this type of position where you
gain time with the night coming to e5 or
you take with the pawn let's say
something like this when this can be a
funny win over peace so after that
chronic is playing g6 and this is a good
multi-purpose move it prepares a
possible retreat and it covers the King
side here h4 was played and this is to
pollow's big new idea he played the part
of his preparation of this lee and now
it's a chrome Nick's turned to react to
that they're absolutely principled move
here would have been light takes a
five-night xe5 and then f6 but I guess
he didn't dare to do that because white
has this sacrifice which leads to really
crazy plane and this can be very
difficult to play against if you know
that your opponent or you suspect that
the opponent has analyzed this at home
with a computer so he probably didn't
want to do that in addition there's this
possibility which also looks like why
has gained some attack it's I don't know
it we it's a [ __ ] it's a bit fishy or
this but it looks very dangerous from
the black point of view I believe okay
plate f5 which is not not really bad
it's just a blocking move to be secure
on the kingside bishop h2 now very good
move but Apollo he secures his important
sure and the next couple of moves back
from Nick really are really problematic
on what I expected he actually is that
you take the pawn which looks a bit ugly
but it's a pawn I guess you should just
have a pawn for your somewhat weakened
position I mean you have really a
strange kind of stone wall here with the
night on age 5 and all kinds of defects
in your position I guess you should just
take a pawn to at least have something
white has no direct refutation he needs
to play on the queenside just like
nothing as special has happened I think
you should have done that to be honest
yeah b6 before and now he played f4 and
I believe this is really really not a
good move it leaves too many weaknesses
behind but i understand that he felt the
pressure after the part of the
interesting novelty with age from ya
after castles he played a five and in
fact i believe after this move black is
beyond beyond salvation he probably
needed to play something like that it's
not much fun but it's probably what he
needed to do it's pretty much says that
okay i know this was a faulty plan were
there for AI really don't know what
advice to give like I mean yeah a5 the
problem was that now be five is coming
and it's simply it's simply a terrible
position if you try to keep the
queenside closed white will later open
up the e-file with Queenie to any form
it's not fun at all he tried the capture
but after taking here and Bishop to b5
we see that all those pieces have no
future the only way to activate them is
actually what chronic play t try to get
the porn back on c6 but that run into
this technical trick on d5 it's not he
didn't overlook it of course it was just
that black didn't have anything else and
after that we get some some trades
after here the smoke is cleared check
wide emerges with an end game with this
beep on being the yapping the trump card
and this is just dead lost because the
beep on is nicely supported by the
bishop as well after a couple of months
yes check check check yeah yes very
quick I know but it is really a complete
win already round here here Kramnik
resigned the game and yeah very tough
loss for him setting him back to fifty
percent in this tournament it's really
it's very it's very quick in this
tournament that fortune changes on all
the positions change just yesterday
kramnik had a winning position at one
point against Aronian it could have been
on plus two with excellent position in
the tournament now he's back to fifty
percent and really would have a hard
time to to catch up what a part of has
bounced back is also on fifty percent
now so yeah he's back in the race after
this tough loss day before okay one game
left aronian and raking and usually I
try to keep this video's around 20
minutes i will go slightly above that
but um yeah what can you do there wasn't
a really dull game today okay we see
that aronian varies a bit he does not
play d4 but place the reggie opening in
a gambit fashion you can give up this
pawn and the red drake in a draicon that
took it this is known as a wretched
Gambon and opening that i have played
myself a number of times and widest
trying to get the porn back with his
knights and yeah like does not really
want to return the porn without a fight
so he plays queen deform very honey i
think is that under 18 is really taking
time for that he seems to be taken of
god by the line and finds it all over
the board which is quite remarkable yeah
aronian with the peace sacrifice on c6
and he will get this rook in the corner
if he didn't invent
in the game this has been played before
in a number of games and in fact I windy
here Bishop d7 by and raking is a new
move and novelty but look at the clock
time for this yet or already spent more
than 70 minutes he was finding it all
over the board and inform a games h5 has
been played yet here we Gavin forget a
very complicated position with white
having a rook and pawn against two minor
pieces but black obviously has the key
on d8 not ideal and still the rook on a
trade yeah after a couple of more moves
we see that white has gotten his looks
into play and black girls trying to
coordinate his pieces he got the rook
into the game very important and started
to secure the king however in this
position after Queen Queen to be three
and draken played the movie form and
this turns out to be a mistake as after
Luke c4 which was played by him by
Iranian why does almost winning here
here is the first a spot where he could
have yeah check check first here the
first spot where we could have finished
off the game I believe with Bishop takes
e4 94 route b8 this will lead to to a
lost endgame as all this is forced and
white now has two points and rook
against to minus with Queenie seven he
will exchange Queens and this is a
winning endgame pretty easily they
didn't do that you played rugby for this
is still okay Quincy six and now here is
the the cleanest win Bishop takes e4 has
now just flat-out winning the idea is
that after night before you can take
here and this really kills black check
this will be a background mate and while
this check also would be a background
mate check yeah we should be formed it
was just just a winner but he went for
Luke
takes D 7 which is an understandable
decision in a way because it gets by
force into this end game which if now he
would have taken with the bishop which
he didn't do I would have been I think
easily winning bissap takes group takes
rupaiya 7 and then you let the airport
run and wide wins almost automatically
instead he took with the rook which is
really mysterious to me I don't really
know why I did that after rook t2a for
Luke a to you cannot move the apron and
you're simply a worse in in comparison
to the the bishop capture yeah and it's
it's here it's already really tricky to
winner leave it still should be winning
but it is tricky and mysteriously enough
a couple of moves later they even
exchanged off this night and now the
rook endgame I believe is a draw I mean
maybe some great analyst comes up with
some great ideas but I don't see it I
just think that black with this active
rook just a couple of moves later we see
that the rook is always attacking here
and attacking here and I really believe
you cannot win this anymore as white as
nice as it looks but it's just not an
ideal position with the King being
passive here on the first rank yeah a
couple of moves later in fact it all
fizzled out to a draw so a very
disappointing finish for Aronian who
could have won the game rather easily at
I mean for this level you always need to
keep in mind that those players they
don't miss much and normally aronian
finds all those moves it's a and it's
attempted not even a question of finding
it they just blatantly obvious I already
don't know sometimes people just have an
off day and it's hard to explain it it's
it's only a very very tough thing here
to to swallow I mean this is really a
half point that can be can be a decisive
and in the
one so I'm really a bit of a
disappointment for aronian alright so
that's it for around six the quick
summary you also can watch single videos
for each game I hope you enjoyed this
quick wrap-up I'll be back on Friday
with round seven thanks for watching